I have long hair again and not because
I'm sad thanks are usually a sign of
sadness extensions are a sign of just
boredom announcement I've decided that
for the month of November I'm gonna be
making fun Monday through Friday like I
used to do a while ago and I guess I'm
gonna start doing now that means
asterisk I will try day a lot of people
do vlogmas or blocked Oberer things like
that and I don't really do those though
I've arbitrarily decided that for the
month of November I will be committed to
five videos a week it's kind of a means
to hopefully get some creative juices
flowing don't they get you guys excited
about this channel again then you can
expect regular videos and I don't know
this might be terrible it might be great
will likely be terrible and will repress
it really deep down at the end of the
month but hey it's going to happen and
you would think that if I had planned
this I would have planned any ideas or
videos or stuff for this and to have it
my plan is that the anxiety associated
with the social accountability of
announcing this type of thing makes me
do it on top of that I thought I would
categorize each day of the week so you
can start to know what you're gonna
expect for the month of November here's
how it breaks down
get Monday sexy related videos to get
your Monday grumpiness off to a pervy
start didn't think through any of the
descriptions of this Tuesday screw this
sounds a lot like [ __ ] Mondays when I
say it out loud but it's not it's just
videos where I screw around in one way
or another cute day when there's a week
you anaise and we're advice related
videos just maybe how to use and DIYs on
Thursday the Fridays will be Friday and
we're commenting on comments you saw my
last video if you watched it my vlogging
camera fell into a lake and so it
currently doesn't work so it might be
commenting on comments it's Friday and
then once again new camera we might get
back to friary who knows
these are established days of the week
but I'm allowed at any point to veer
from the establishment because I make
the rules please subscribe so that's
what's happening this month get excited
that's the big announcement and then I
thought because it's Wednesday we would
start off with a cue and Wednesday going
on
Twitter and asked you guys what you
needed advice on and a hashtag great
grace advice so let's just jump right
into it My partner broke up with me on
Halloween my birthday is tomorrow which
wine pairs nicely with Twix and tears
all of the wine and then you can recycle
the bottle by breaking it over your
ex-partners car and slashing the tires
with it I don't advocate that I'm just
saying how to write a 30 page thesis
without pulling your hair out shave your
head how do I get out of this
non-metaphorical box in my experience
you got officially out of it how do you
handle stress a man handle it a door
handle it I show at the door both bad
how to politely leave a party slash
social event without being rude just
start incorporating in conversations to
people that you're an actual ghost then
you don't have to feel rude about
leaving people will probably ask you to
leave how do I stop procrastinating so
much try amateur crafting it's only
gonna get worse this month do you think
if I click bait my resume cover letter
with say best resume ever
I'll get more interviews no you gotta
click bandit with former david dobrik
assistant parentheses emotional how do I
look at the Sun without hurting my eyes
I don't have children but I can imagine
looking directly at your own spawn is
disgusting so it might just be a feeling
that doesn't go away I need to lose
about 25 kilograms by June July help a
brother out thanks in advance dog
speaking of says hi to goose who is a
stranger in the Internet Society oh if
you want to lose 25 kilograms like June
or July I would say run about 3 to 5
minutes for every Trump tweet that is
extremely detrimental to our world at
large how do I nail a phone interview
for a real adult job I really want I
would say about 30 seconds before the
phone interview starts send a dick pic
how do I get my dog to stop hogging the
bed okay first of all you have to stop
calling your a walk a dog that might be
why they're a little offended and
passive-aggressively
stealing half the bed I graduate in
December and I don't know how to
decorate my caps help three words for
you
hot blue dildos how do you do social
media life and IRL so well kind of
boggles my mind
fired when you are in charge of your
social media you're in control of
keeping out the bad I'm a full raccoon
garbage human but online I'm only like
half how can I start a conversation
without being awkward
don't touch the genitals yours are
theirs it's a good start
what do you do if a waiter says enjoy
your meal and you say you too you
maintain eye contact with the waiter no
blinking start peeing your pants openly
and then throw a smoke bomb and log-roll
your way out of the restaurant ok guys
that's it for this cute and Wednesday
let me know in the comments down below
any ideas for videos that I should be
doing throughout the month of November
or people that you'd like to see me
collaborate with because I will be
collaborating with people I'm very
excited make sure that you are
subscribed to this YouTube channel
because hopefully five videos a week
will be being produced we'll see
other than that I don't know should I
sprint down the street while drunk no
you should AT&T down the street it's
only gonna get worse